like much more in line with like you
would want covariate balancing that
seems like it would make you do better
at that so it feels like the trade-off
would be different there so i'm curious
about that kind of classical notion of
robustness versus the notion of
robustness you've introduced which is
average over all of these like uh
covariate virtue camera ones
yeah so
a couple let me just clarify our
definition it's has nothing to do with
covariates
it means that
you know i'm going to run a randomized
experiment there are many possible
potential outcomes that could be true i
don't know which ones
but within some ball i just find an l2
ball within some ball
i want to make sure that my mean square
for everything in this ball is not too
large and i should make a design
that satisfies that that's what a roblox
design is for us i admit the term robust
is like overloaded
um
but so our definition of robustness has
nothing to do with uh covariates
necessarily
um now
you asked a question which was what
about if you want to estimate treatment
effects you know on sub pop populations
of people in your study here not just on
all so i wrote our you know our s demand
of interest is the average human effect
over everyone
in the study um if you wanted to do
multiple s demands
you know at the same time that's
something that i do not know as well but
i know that people think about that so i
really have no good answer besides uh
that's not what we're doing that's a
very cool thing and i would presume that
coverage balancing would be a good thing
but i don't know like in what ways like
rigorous lee i don't know that
cool thanks a lot
um
just questions
so you're using very large interventions
that's s that are like linear size right
um as you scale that down you just have
to and then you have a very small sample
size like log n if i'm not mistaken do
you if i reduce s do i pay inversely
yeah actually we have not explored that
that's a very nice question um
yeah i mean obviously there's a very
simple thing that you can do where you
just intervene at every node and that is
linearly many interventions we show that
if you can intervene on a constant
fraction of the nodes then you can do
logarithmic many interventions i don't
know the trade-off in between uh yeah
most of your deduction was fairly local
anyway so it seems like it should just
like you have to hit everywhere seem
like right you mean some kind yeah like
a hitting set kind of structure too
yeah
uh yeah i don't know the exact
dependence but yeah
can i follow up on this question yeah um
in terms of like the first part where
you just have let's say two variables i
think it's really exciting that you know
how to trade off between interventional
and observational data
so if you can allow yourself soft
interventions you could just intervene
on both
and it seems at least from simulations i
think also frederick has done that in
the soft intervention setting you should
be able to actually reduce the number of
samples as compared to hard
interventions do you have any intuition
and have you looked at that like how
soft interventions would actually even
be better as compared to the new ones no
that's a great question yeah so this is
very recent work we haven't actually had
any chance to explore further uh but
yeah yeah we'll uh yeah let's talk
yeah and for the structure learning and
for the just the parameter learning
would be really exciting to know
thanks
this question's for chris
two questions i guess one question was
on so is the estimate actually at the
end based on the the randomization
procedure produced actually unbiased
estimate of the treatment effect and the
second question is related to inference
so you briefly mentioned the very end
about the confidence interval
construction being potentially
conservative versus that i presume
compared to let's say a covariate
adjusted
one or maybe even just a straight up
horvitz thompson kind of just without
any coverage so can you just comment on
like that kind of
practical like i guess the inferential
question so suppose i optimize between
the robustness and uh the efficiency of
the robustness and these characteristics
but what would the inferential
characteristics look like
seems like the talk was mainly focused
on the msc
balancing not so much in the
infrastructure thank you yeah so that
was a lot uh let me know if i don't get
to one of your questions here uh all
very good um
the first thing is that yes this
robustness
you know okay so first off the very
first question is it's you asked we're
using the harvest thompson s estimator
uh our design we know the marginal
probabilities and treatment they're all
like one one half you can modify that if
you want i didn't go into half but you
can modify that
um so whenever you know
the individual marginal probabilities of
treatment and whenever they're bounded
away from zero and one
uh in this design based setting here uh
the estimator is on is unbop biased so
our design definitely satisfies that so
we definitely have an unbiased estimator
that was your first question
um
the other questions so
yes the robustness
uh
versus covariate balance that's all
thinking about mean squared error
okay and so i think that
in general and this is not a formal
statement i'm making
but it's my
experience that if you want to
you know design an experiment to make
mean squared error of an estimator small
that's a different it's a
related but generally different thing
from making uh your confidence intervals
very small
unless you're willing to make some
normal assumption then it's the same
thing i think
um so i actually don't know like what a
general design satisfying robustness and
covariant balance
i don't know what the
like analog robustness and covariate
balance is for confidence intervals you
could do it for we gave this gaussian
result which gives you tail bounds
um and from those tail bounds you can
get confidence intervals but those whole
and finite samples
so they're going to be loose a lot of
times
whereas a normal approximation it's
exact in some appropriate limit which
usually feels reasonable in practice
so
um
yeah like our confidence intervals are
larger than that you'd get you've made a
normal but you could make a normal
approximation
which says the variance of your
estimator is all that really matters for
determining the width if you use our
design you know the variance is small
you know if the outcomes are related to
the covariates and if you've chosen the
balance
so because you get increased
like you know precision with our design
in certain
cases
if you had a central limit theorem
that would that would carry over to like
small confidence intervals in that way
um did that answer the ques i think i
kind of rambled around the things that
you asked did that answer the question
more or less
thank you thanks
i know
sorry
yeah i have a question to chris uh so it
seems that your design
uh i mean your goal is to have the mean
square error be bounded as a function of
the approximation uh with respect to
linear functions right yes yes so if you
generalize the class of linear functions
to other
classes of functions i mean are very
interesting discrepancy problems which
come out sending it up that way well um
there are things we can do yes are they
interesting that's up to debate um you
can extend everything i've done to
kernel methods and so that's a that's
and that's like a chapter in the
dissertation that i have it's not in the
paper uh that we have on archive i hope
it'll be its own kind of paper once i
flesh out some other details and stuff
but
what we've done is we've said let me
tell you what that result looks like
we say okay the variance is is uh of the
horwitz thompson estimator is bounded
above
by some ridge regression
where you're looking over linear
functions
there's a way to do a kernel trick in
this grammatical walk it's like it's the
exact way you think it would work
and instead of a linear
like ridge regression you do a kernel
ridge regression so if you want to
extend to non-linear function spaces if
you're willing to use kernels
pretty much everything works in the
exact same way there's like slight minor
things you need to be careful of but
it's pretty much the exact same way
um
i think that interesting
non-linear functions could be like what
if it's a sparse
linear function like there's some parts
under function it's good i don't know
which one
i that to me is i have no idea what to
do there
um
yeah i don't know yeah so there there
there's def but you know in terms of
rkhs
not so interesting in the sense that the
same methodology still works interesting
that you can do that
outside of rkhs many open questions i
would say thanks
i can guess my questions
hi chris uh nice talk so uh you
mentioned that you want to think about
the online version of the algorithm and
there is the self-balancing work which
tries to solve the same problem in an
online manner
uh
do you like is there a concern like why
that is not appropriate or is that i
know it has this extra root log factor
or something is that
the main reason or there are some other
reasons that you think it's not
appropriate here um there's one like
super main reason that it won't work
which is that so you may reference this
paper i forget
the author's exact names but it's lss
and it came out maybe a year or two ago
maybe a year ago
and i looked at it a lot
and
they solve a discrepancy problem so it's
not this distributional thing but they
do distributional stuff so like
you know it's not it's not too far you
know to modify the real problem is that
their assignments they allow for plus
one minus one
and
zero or plus one minus one and like
three i think are two
so
they don't
and it's a great paper so let me not i
i'm i'm very excited by that paper uh
but
in this context it doesn't quite work
because you can't have
like someone just not be assigned to
treatment or it's a very odd thing if
you if you did that
it could very well like
mess up the uh estimator that you have
and
you know there's i mean there's some
care to be done there but it is kind of
weird to like just drop someone nice so
actually i have a follow-up work on that
and we can talk offline that you don't
have to do what they do you can always
assign but uh you can always assign plus
minus one you don't have to do zero
uh and you can still do things so we can
work offline yeah you you
yes i'm very curious we'll talk
so for the observational study i would
assume that depends on how the
observational study is than they
actually unfactor into the complexity
calculation too right
so
what is the observational study right if
it's not very informative about the
possible cultural effect right then
you will need a lot of them so i don't
know whether in your bond whether you
see that or not
because there are many different
observational studies could be relevant
and they
some probably more helpful for causal
influence than others
do you see something like that in your
strategical work
i think i don't fully understand the
question so your question is that
if
your observations don't reveal the
causal structure
yeah there's a different degree that the
observational study can help you to view
for example why observations that can
have a lot more confounding factors than
others right
do you see something like that to
characterize that in your stress yeah
yeah yeah i think right so i mean
i guess you're referring to the first
part of my talk right where we were yeah
so in order to generalize it to i mean
uh more number of variables or where you
have more
confounding uh you would need
yeah i mean like um so
you'd need a more detailed understanding
of how
uh observation i mean
if you have more observations i mean you
can i mean there's still a bottleneck
you do need interventions you see that
even in this simple example with two
variables but um
but right i mean so
yeah i mean you need to kind of uh we
still haven't looked at it at all but
like we you'd need kind of a
the graphical structure
of the different variables will
definitely come into play when
determining the trade-off between the
number of observations and number of
interventional examples
yeah yeah
thanks
question for you i
i'm not so familiar with the types of
trees that that you were uh describing
and so i was wondering so my first
reaction was oh dear this is going to
explode the moment that i have a large
speed space never mind if i go
continuous or something like that so
what i then was wondering is that okay
firstly i was thinking well
how do you think about the
generalization conceptually of this to
the continuous space if at all
this is not going to work that's
completely hopeless
and then secondly i was wondering to
what extent
um
uh
these this sort of representation
relates to other representations say
if you wanted to do this in terms of
potential outcomes for example that i i
don't know if you have something to say
about that
yeah so
so yeah everything that we've been doing
so far is in this street setting and
honestly i think it's a really great
question to consider
what could be done in the continuous
setting but
currently i have no thoughts on the on
that question but i think it's a really
good one and worth exploring
um
but uh
yeah in terms of potential outcomes and
other things one
i think recently at the like stanford
online calls london seminar
i think thomas richardson was giving a
talk about some recent work with uh
maybe jamie rubin about uh
models for
i can't remember what they're called but
uh they were they were a new family of
models where they were using essentially
augmented dags to explore like how you
go about modeling potential outcomes and
things like this
so i think it is worth sort of exploring
how these cs trees relate to these other
sort of context-specific models and in
particular that family
and
perhaps from that perspective we could
see something like potential outcomes i
know also that in regards to
[Music]
computing potential outcomes there's
been some work in with within a group at
google deepmind who's been using these
stage tree methods to actually
to model these things
so exploring the relation between how
they've been looking at
stage trees and how it might connect to
this specific family of cs trees
could shed some light on it but i
haven't thought about it so much so far
so
thanks
so this seems to be very orthogonal to
somehow what we have heard for example
in the morning right on the invariance
principle where we're looking at you
know what what is causal is maybe um
should be something that is invariant to
all of the different environments or all
of the different contexts
um whereas you're looking at within a
context right they could behave
differently so there seems to be like
it's exactly in the in the opposite
direction so how would you even connect
to something like kiara's talk in the
morning
where you know this is exactly what
she's using is this invariance together
these causal
right yeah i mean i guess in
some sense maybe i don't quite get the
question but i guess in some sense
we are still using variances to get at
causal effects but now we're doing it
within the context so to me that's sort
of the natural connection but i'm i'm
not sure much beyond beyond that what
you have in mind yeah you could actually
even more use like different kinds of
environments
yeah absolutely that sounds completely
worth thinking about
there's a question uh from thomas uh
thomas i believe if you unmute then you
because your fan was you can actually
talk
can you hear me
uh yeah so i was just following off on
liam's comment so that i think the grasp
probably was single world intervention
graphs and i i was going to add as a
quick comment that i don't think i
didn't mention it in the seminar but um
we have we've given a little example um
in in uh
paperwork illustrator where we we did
something context specific and
we showed that uh you could get
some identification results um from
context-specific uh
independence that uh that you you can't
get and this this is for an ordinary
intervention distribution um and
and we we gave a kind of you know semi
plausible example as to how the
context-specific independence could
arise uh
and one other comment there's paper by
some authors uh from finland uh some of
them at uvascular that also were
using context-specific independence and
had a kind of context-specific breast
and do calculus so i just throw that in
there as well
yeah so the question for first
so
i want to understand the z
when the dependence between the z when
you do this like a trade-off between
capacity and foreign
like features can you say something
about what the z is yes yes uh
yeah so i didn't mention it too much but
we kind of know what grandson walk does
for certain input covariate vectors
so if your covariate vectors are
orthogonal
then your augmented covariate vectors no
matter what fee you set are still
orthogonal
and balancing those turns out to be the
bernoulli design so if you gave me
you know covariates which were thought
orthogonal i think this is a question
that you're asked to give me orthogonal
covariate that vectors i run the
algorithm no matter what i said that
trade-off to be i will always get the
bernoulli design and you might say wait
how are we balancing robustness and
um
robustness and uh covariative balance
well it turns out that in that setting
robustness is equal to covariate balance
because i can take an orthogonal
transformation of your covariates get
the identity matrix
so like the covariance of z is that
operating arm is equal to the operator
covariance x z you can just do an
orthogonal transformation
so that's in that that's it so there's
yeah there's some settings where
there is a real trade-off that's like
most covariate vectors but there are
some weird ones like the orthogonal
where there essentially is no trade-off
um all the results still apply they just
become less interesting at that point
[Music]
you said at the end you're also
interested in looking at
how you might learn the graph
uh in the first place
and placing bounds and can you say a
little bit more about that because i was
actually very curious about how that
would go you know especially if we're
sequencing independence tests and and uh
earlier choice or earlier decisions
might influence what sort of subsequent
tests we're doing
can you
i realize it's an open problem that you
mentioned but i'm curious
yeah i mean
right as i said i mean even without
interventions
um and learning the markov equivalence
class
understanding what is the sample
complexity of learning the markov
equivalence graph lies in or
an approximate part of equivalence class
in the sense that uh the graph expresses
a distribution which is close in some
sense to the to the given distribution
that that
is still an open question uh so with
interventions as far as i know there
really has not been any work i mean
trying to understand this trade-off
between the samples observational
samples and interventional samples that
you need in order to discover a causal
graph
i think we're just discussing with other
people i think this is a super
interesting problem um
yeah i mean there are some trivial
things you can say like you can
of course intervene
on every node and
in that way you can learn uh who the
parents are
but doing everything in a
computationally efficient way and also
minimizing number of interventions this
full trade-off is far from understood
right now yeah
[Applause]
are there any announcements from the
organizers for tomorrow otherwise no
we'll just uh meet for coffee again at
9am and then at 9 30 we'll get started